hello freak [ __ ] was after the fight
I'm in the back and I see Aamir Khan
Terence Crawford and Andre Berto and so
I go to talk to them and they were all
like super complimentary of Conor
McGregor like dude he can box man I'm
like right like what you think you're
just gonna look like an [ __ ] like
Bart's it's like would you expect to
happen like we just didn't expecting to
get any rounds we thought he's just
gonna be outclassed like nah man look
yes - belief in himself and he had a
weird style that that strange style of
off-speed punches extending his arms
fully and then pop them in there and
Paul in the vacuum polly goes I gotta be
honest I was kind of glad to see that
because when I went against him like the
first four or five rounds I couldn't
land [ __ ] because that style like it
takes forever just get used to yeah I
don't know what to do you think so
I just thought maybe I was having off
day but once I see that I see Floyd do
this kind of the same thing you know
granted Floyd fought a different style I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah that Styles legit
now he's legit you know I mean that's
just too big a leap that's all it is for
Conor to go and his first professional
fight fight arguably the greatest
fighter of all time
it's like he's a hundred percent in the
mix now he's won or T and Oh get fifty
you know it's a hundred percent in the
mix that he's the greatest fighter of
all time you think about defensively no
one's even close
no one's been hit as little as him and
Hunter hit him yeah he beat everybody
and obviously fought Conor a different
way than he fought everybody else that's
a fact but if Connor hit him more than
any fighter that ever you the other
thing here's kudos to Conor and Floyd
but especially Conor when's the last
time you saw an exciting Floyd
Mayweather fight true kind of went at
him yeah that's when we got out of the
fight I made him turn him into a Mexican
so they say that like yeah you didn't
heard that no comment I missed a lot of
it Conor brought the fight out of them
okay the first time since I don't know
who the watchman you can say well that's
the finish was Victor ities that was
[ __ ] that's cheap shot you really didn't
bring it to him but this brought it out
of them it was legit oh man and when I
watch it the second time knowing the
result then you really appreciate what
Floyd's doing because although Conor did
catch him he definitely caught him with
a hard uppercut in the first round but
that was interesting because that was
like oh [ __ ] like you got to realize
mind your P's and Q's this guy's legit
but Connor never me even though he
clipped him with that shot never really
heard him he's got one shot to the body
which I was surprised I gotta be honest
in my prediction I thought Connor was
gonna do well like you did in the first
rounds I called that I thought he's
gonna ruin 4 to 5 rounds and then I
thought you'd wanna break up would
wobble him and that would be enough to
win Connor kind of the spectacle but
just it can't you know Floyd's chin and
you know just the boxing powers a little
different man it definitely is different
I don't think Connor is loading up
either you know I don't think Connor is
really like digging in on these shots
cuz I think he was probably concerned
about his endurance you got to realize
also this fight was relatively short
notice
so short notice that I had already
booked the DC improv in advance and it
was sold out by the time they announced
the fight correct so are not the DC
improv the Warner Theatre in DC so if
you think about that that's [ __ ]
months in advance three months they did
this fight was announced three months
ago that's nothing that's nothing for
this magnitude of a fight most the time
a fight like this is six seven months
out oh my god maybe more when did they
announce Canelo tripled in a long term
while I think between the time they
announced it and when the fight starts I
got a feel like it's five months at
least at least one which is norm I would
assume but but at least they but they
also boxing was smart because they set
it up right so the ad Cannella wish
Chavez Jr there's a joke but that was
literally just a setup to get him to
trip to triple G and they both knew it
usually looking at basically a year in
the making and before that what two
years in the making and here's more
importantly during that entire time
they're both box so Connors not he's not
really sure if he's gonna actually have
this boxing match with Floyd Mayweather
right so he knocks out Eddie Alvarez and
then somehow another the rumblings get
started but that's just not enough time
well did you do you he wants to prepare
for Floyd I agree especially in that
arena the best of all time in that
different arena and Floyd goes listen I
tried making this fight before this and
the us he turned it down
and he goes alright we'll see what
happens and then he goes and I came back
and was like yo this how much money we
could make he was and then they're like
alright let's do it you
I try to make this fight a while ago but
even before this yeah I remember the
discussions but to be to be that close
like when they actually announced it
okay this is actually happening crazy
it's crazy to have it so quickly switch
to this man to a fight
yeah it's nuts so if something like that
if you gave Conor like six months maybe
he could get in better shape or he could
survive he's always going to fit he's
he's never going to be against a guy
like Mayweather was so efficient and his
movement is so crisp and this how I was
describing it to a friend of mine I was
like does your friend have a boxing your
martial arts background no any faster he
was trying to figure out like why he
would get so tired captain and I said I
go okay when you tie your shoe you tie
your shoe you don't even think about is
go right now but if you have to think
about tying your shoes it takes more
energy and you have to think and then
you got your tents I go Floyd's just
tying shoes he's reacting yeah he's just
so he's so good he's been doing it so
long that he's just got it ingrained in
his movements Conor has to think way
more than Floyd does and Floyd is
constantly pressuring him so cars
backing up all time which wears you out
and also the volume of punches you know
he set a really high pace he thought I
think he thought he was gonna be able to
stop him maybe a little more stop him
from coming forward he wasn't prepared
when you know when Floyd put his head in
his chest and did work the ref didn't
allow him to get his rest in the clinch
but listen at the end of the day I'm all
about the glitch in the matrix man I
think Conor is a glitch it was so much
fun that even pulled this off it's
awesome
he didn't dishonor the sport I thought
he did really well the only that I told
College that I'm proud of him an i what
he did we win or lose and this is not
his belief in himself seem credible but
even that is not enough if you fight a
better boxer and your body gets tired so
that's what we saw in that fight in the
beginning of the fight if he could have
maintained somehow or another if he was
in good enough shape that he could
maintain the pace that he had formed he
had in the first three rounds for the
entire 12 gotta fight it's a well away
different fighter because he's dangerous
he's quick he's moving away he has a
huge endurance problem and this is like
something that comes back to for boxing
obviously you don't see hasn't rum in
UFC as well he may because if you look
at his a trillion Nate Diaz fight with
that boy I went five rounds is fine yeah
but if you look at his attributes I'd
say endurance is you know in everyone
knows I'm a kind of dick writer but if
you go on you know his strengths right
I'd say it's at the bottom yes as far as
his strengths I agree it's not bad where
it's like you know it's not good it's
not good look here's the best endurance
in the sport Mighty Mouse for sure well
he doesn't count he's out true
you're home twenty five pounds you're
out Cain Velasquez counts Cain Velasquez
did countless cats at the height of his
career you know who else has phenomenal
cardio Neil Magny no magnesia the
Gazelle has some phenomenal phenomenal
cardio
[Applause]
[Music]